in Westworld season 3 episode 5 sirok
tells his story he and his brother Jean
me lost their homes when Paris was
destroyed in a thermonuclear incident
this shot of them walking through yellow
fields looks just like Maeve's memories
they both remember the tragic loss of an
idealized past serac and Jean me
believed humanity would destroy itself
through disaster and conflict so they
decided to save the world with a
god-like computer called Rehoboam
earlier versions were called soul David
and Solomon who were a line of kings in
the Bible Rehoboam needed data so serac
and jean me worked with Liam Dempsey
senior the father of Liam jr. because
Liam's tech company insight had the
entire world's data people's calls texts
purchases jobs relationships everything
and with this data
Rehoboam could predict the future and
change the future by making choices and
tweaking variables to cause the outcomes
you want
so Soraka and Jean me charted a course
for the entire human race they reshaped
the world to prevent disasters and bring
order represented by this black circle
and it worked for years the world was
under their control but serac says
there's a problem because the data shows
that in the future the system will fail
leading to human extinction or the end
of the world but you gotta wonder if
this disaster might actually be a
self-fulfilling prophecy caused by a
serac system like Dolores described
earlier the system can't keep control
because some people are outliers and
agitators who can't be predicted serac
says that Dolores is one of these people
and so is his brother John me so serac
experimented with editing people
changing their personality to make them
easier to control this facility looks a
lot like the Mesa where hosts were
programmed so the idea is that humans
are controlled just like the robots of
West world were serac is saving humanity
by reducing humanity into a system
following code also serac murders Liam
dempsey senior for opposing him just as
Liam jr. hinted it's not revealed what
happened to Jean me after serac edited
him he just says he left his brother
behind but throughout the story serac
refers to Rehoboam as you as though it's
a person maybe Rehoboam is Jean me like
maybe serac put his beloved brother's
mind into the computer he created like
how Ford lived on inside the cradle we
know that human hosts brains black
spheres speckled with red which does
look a bit like Rehoboam maybe John me
became one with a computer God Sosa recs
backstory is a mix of great ambition and
great tragedy we see more of house Iraq
controls the world he meets with the
president of Brazil who totally kisses
her axe are saying he's honored and he
respects him and he wants to meet at his
presidential palace but serac has the
meet on the runway for sir axe plane
which is a huge power move like Zurich
is so powerful that world leaders come
to him at his convenience serac knows
from Rehoboam surveillance that this
president is corrupt which could lead to
rebellion by separatists so serac
threatens to replace the president
taught a ruin Brazil's economy unless he
gets his [ __ ] together
so serac uses data technology to
influence politics and economics which
is already starting to happen in the
real world
algorithms decide what news and shows
and YouTube videos we see social media
and advertising affect elections and
psychology location tracking and face
recognition are tools of surveillance
and insights profiles are very similar
to the social credit system in China
which restricts employment and travel
for people deemed untrustworthy serac
takes these real-world technologies to
the extreme using data to keep the world
stable and peaceful and devoid of free
will throughout the scene flies buzz
around the president flyers are
important in West world in season one
dolorous killing a fly showed that she
was going off her programming so this
president's failure to spot of
I might show his failure to escape sir
acts control
Dolores once told a story about a
disease spread by flies
she said sick cows should be put down
but this season Bernard tried to help an
injured cow that was buzzing with flies
so flies can represent the sickness and
weakness and self-destructive nature of
humanity but Nod wants to protect the
sick humans
Dolores may want them put down but serac
wants to control them all serac learns
of encrypted communication between
Jakarta Berlin San Francisco and Los
Angeles which seems to be the Dolores is
communicating Dolores and Martin loris
are in LA around the insight office
Charlotte is in San Francisco at the
Dallas office Jakarta is kind of near
Singapore so maybe Musashi loris is
there now but Berlin is a mystery we
know Dolores had five pearls one was
Charlotte on Martin won Musashi won
Bernard which leaves one mystery pearl
maybe this is another copy of Dolores
perhaps in a body of Clementine or Peter
or someone he in Berlin Dolores and
Caleb have Liam captive but Liam injects
Caleb with genre the party drug that
Roderick gave him last episode the drug
gives Caleb the experience of a series
of movie genres Sharona Jonathan Nolan
said this was inspired by the gum in
Willy Wonka that gives the experience of
a three-course meal Caleb does not
become a blueberry but he does go black
and white in his first your honor
experience film noir then when a car
chase begins the genre switches to
action then we hear the ride of the
Valkyries which was famously used in the
movie Apocalypse Now these shots of cars
sweeping around a similar to the shots
of the choppers in the movie Dolores
blows up their enemies with explosives
on an autonomous motorbike
some fans theorized that this bike might
have had Dolores as fifth Pole inside it
and that it had the mind of Dolores as
horse then Caleb's genre switches to
romance we hear the theme from the 1970
movie love story as Caleb gazes
longingly at Dolores while she guns down
attackers there was a hidden West world
called when Caleb meets Dolores which is
edited to make the season seem like an
update romance movie so the story has
played with the idea of love between
Dolores and Caleb in Caleb's next genre
he hears nightclubbing by Iggy Pop which
was famously used in Trainspotting a
movie about heroin users so it's fitting
music for a drug trip on a train a
finally music from the shining place as
Caleb starts to question his sanity
Westworld
has always played with different genres
Westworld itself
explores the western genre and shogun
world is its mirror in samurai style
Westworld season 2 played with a mystery
film noir genre and season 3 is a
cyberpunk thriller with a detour into a
war movie Westworld is obsessed with
different styles of storytelling and how
they affect how we see the world
art is a mind-altering substance
meanwhile Bernard and Martin laura's
infiltrate the inside company Vinod
tells Martin to question Dolores as
orders and to think for himself but
Martin stays loyal to Dolores and later
willingly dies for her plan but maybe
the other copies like Charlotte Loras
and Musashi Loras will think for
themselves and follow their own paths
Bernard says living another person's
life changes you so maybe Charlotte
Loras will become more like Charlotte
and choose to be with her son Nathan
maybe the reason why Martin Loras died
loyal and dutiful is because the real
human Martin was loyal and dutiful it
seems like these copies combine aspects
of Dolores and the humans they're
impersonating just like this Bernard
seems to combine the host Bernard with
the human Arnold before he dies Martin
Loras shows Bernard a facility where
serac edits and reprograms people who
don't fit in his plan it's called
re-education Center Oh three six which
suggests there could be dozens or
hundreds of these places re educating
people on mass it's also called inner
journeys recovery which is the place
where William went last episode so maybe
serac is trying to reprogram William and
maybe Bernard will come save him
Williams spent all of season one
following Arnold's Mays metaphor for
consciousness in season two william met
bernard who's based on arnold maybe now
in inner journeys recovery william and
burn arnold will finally discuss the
center of the maze bernard is rescued by
Stubbs it's kind of suspicious how
easily Stubbs gets into the inside
building maybe Stubbs is the second mole
who secretly works for serac but now it
thinks that Dolores has a plan for him
Martin said that Bernard is the only one
we can't replace and that Bernard will
have to choose a side it seems that the
reason why Dolores created this Bernard
even though she knew that he'd try to
stop her is because she respects
Bernards wisdom and his sympathy for
humans since bernard is part Arnold is
connected to both the humans and the
hosts bernard has always been of two
minds if bernard has to choose a side
maybe Dolores will make Bernard decide
humanity's fate maybe she'll consider
wiping out humanity who are putting
humanity in a digital world or in two
host bodies or something but Bernard
will have the final say maybe she'll put
Bernards mind inside Rehoboam so he'll
become a benevolent godlike overseer of
the human world
whatever happens bernard is at the
center of Dolores plan dolores says
she's gonna show everyone in the world
the data that insight has on them she'll
reveal how everyone is watched and
controlled on the paths that Roja Guam
has planned for everyone like how caleb
is predicted to commit suicide so he's
been denied jobs and turned to the
military to die
Liam argues the people shouldn't know
their futures he reveals that Ash's
brother who she's been working to
support will soon die of violent death
so Liam says it's better not to know
because not knowing gives us hope and
hope is what our society is built on
caleb says it's a false hope he tells a
story about rats drowning in a barkat if
the rats know they can't escape they die
quickly and painlessly but if the rats
think there's hope they struggle and
suffer for hours before die
this is based on a real-world study of
rats described in the popular book homo
Deus West world's showrunners have said
that this book was a big influence it
explores consciousness data and
algorithmic control and you can get it
on audiobook for free with an audible
trial at the link below but Caleb's
point is that it's cruel to give people
false hope ads in Episode one say the
good life is waiting but people like
Caleb and ash and giggles will never get
the good life that Liam and his rich
friends enjoy the American dream where
anyone can be rich and successful is a
lie to keep the poor in line the game is
rigged
so Dolores and Martin reveal this
daughter to the world this guy finds out
that his friends think he's crazy
this woman learns that a daughter who
will likely commit suicide this woman
finds out that she's got the genes for
Alzheimer's disease which companies can
already test for in the real world all
over the world people learn terrible
things about themselves and their loved
ones they realize they've been
manipulated and lied to so some riot and
run wild
so is Dolores actually helping humanity
here or is she just making them weaker
so she can take over
maybe people shouldn't know their own
fate Caleb says this shot of the Kaos
looks like these host Bulls last season
first the hosts were freed from their
loops and now humans are freed from
their loops Dolores gets shot and shrugs
it off like it's nothing so caleb is
freaked out he's finally starting to
realize that Dolores isn't human
but when Dolores got shot in episode one
she seemed badly hurt maybe she was
pretending them to manipulate Caleb into
helping her cuz caleb is also more than
he appears at the beach Liam says that
Ash and giggles are nothings who have no
free will and ash proves him wrong by
suddenly shooting him so Liam dies like
he lived this patek billionaire was
pretty much useless and basic but as he
dies Liam says to Caleb you don't even
know who you are you're the worst of
them earlier Liam read Caleb's profile
and looked scared when Caleb accused
of killing his friend Francis Liam said
you think I killed your friend and now
Liam says you did it you did it so it
sounds like Caleb killed Francis and his
memories of the military are false
caleb has flashbacks of some blackops
looking stuff with a mysterious man and
woman credited as Whitman and dr. Greene
we see caleb strapped to a chair in a
facility this could be one of Sirach
sorry education centers where he edits
people to make them more controllable
maybe serac programmed Caleb to work at
this blackops place maybe to hunt down
on other divergent people and then he
edited Caleb's memories so he wouldn't
remember
maybe these changes are why Caleb's
mother doesn't recognize him and maybe
it's why caleb follows dolores like it's
weird that he so suddenly becomes loyal
to her without knowing anything about
her
maybe caleb was programmed to be an
obedient soldier when Caleb freaks out
about these revelations Delora seems
totally unsurprised it seems like she
already knew this stuff so maybe she has
been manipulating Caleb from the start
his mysterious past might be why she
recruited him in the first place we
later see Caleb with bloody hands
another hint that his guilty of killing
his friend francis it's revealed that
the serac flashbacks this episode was
Delores watching sir axe memories from
the Rehoboam daughter learning how to
defeat her enemy they face off via
hologram serac stands for control and
survival and Loras challenges him with
freedom and chaos Ciroc has a cute
wristwatch that shows the circle
representing Rehoboam they used to be
ordered and neat but now it's wild and
chaotic with black spikes which means
the world is deviating from his plan
people are escaping his control and
losing the safety that his control
provided in his plane above the clouds
serac is like a god but for the first
time he looks worried Delores and Caleb
get on a plane maybe they're going to
Berlin to meet the mysterious fifth host
or maybe they'll intercept sir explain
and have some meaty God versus robot
combat or maybe she is going back to
west world but the big mysteries this
episode are what is caleb secret past
what is Dolores planning for Bernard and
William who is the fifth pearl in Berlin
and why couldn't HBO find an actor who
could speak Portuguese properly when ash
and giggles meet Dolores they drop three
quick literary references giggles cause
Liam little lord fauntleroy which refers
to an old story about a boy who inherits
wealth and power just like Liam inherits
wealth and power ash says Liam's wealth
makes King Midas look like Tom Canty in
The Prince and the pauper by Mark Twain
Tom Canty is the pauper meaning a poor
person and in Greek mythology everything
King Midas touches turns to gold there
are lots of references to Greek
mythology in Westworld in season 2 and
early name for the west-world company
was the argos initiative in greek
mythology
Argos was a giant with a hundred
watching eyes and in that same episode
we learned that Westworld was designed
to watch everyone occator goes to the
land of the dead to rescue his love just
like in the Greek myth of Orpheus and
James Delos and the hosts are stuck in
endless futile loops like Sisyphus that
episode is called the riddle of the
Sphinx which itself refers to an Oedipus
myth about a sphinx as riddle to learn
more about Greek myths check out mythos
by stephen fry fry retells the greek
myths and narrates the audiobook himself
you can get mythos or homo Deus or
little Lord Fauntleroy for free right
now by signing up for a trial with
audible members get an audiobook each
month and if you cancel you keep the
audio books you can listen in your plane
above the clouds while chaos reigns
below sign up at audible.com slash ASX
thanks for watching please like and
subscribe
we're holding live streams right after
each episode of Westworld season 3 at
10:30 p.m. Eastern Time Sundays the
patreon supporters can watch live
streams after their broadcast the thanks
to patrons Nathan bowling Joey Soha
a Tulane jerky Emily kg Bale Jesse Jack
Erica Ellen and Laszlo panaflex
Cheers
you